[Music]
kendall Jenner was hospitalized over the
weekend like scared I'm freaking out a
Kardashian source tells et that the
reality star was hospitalized before she
attended the Vanity Fair Oscar party on
Sunday night quote she was working hard
and took a vitamin drip over the weekend
and had a bad reaction kendall checked
herself into cedars-sinai Medical Center
and quickly bounced back that's insane
the source adds quote Kendall works so
much and was exhausted so she got a
vitamin drip as she often does things
didn't go as planned but she was able to
pull it together and look incredible at
the Oscars after parties the whole idea
of a vitamin drip is to get a lot of
vitamins into your system quickly via an
IV bag but there's little evidence the
practice actually has any health
benefits and an eyewitness confirms that
inside the Vanity Fair bash Kendall
looked happy and healthy as she mingled
with gal-pal Joan Smalls
and other partygoers here right as for
the 22 year old and her rumored
boyfriend NBA star Blake Griffin the
source explains that the two are quote
laying low after his ex filed court
documents about him leaving her for
Kendall